the third and the four species of sharks
that I want to share with you tonight is
the oceanic whitetip shark a shark that
has been listed as the fourth most
dangerous species of sharks if you pay
attention to such list it's an animal of
it is a true pelagic predator this
animal lives way out in the open ocean
hunts in deep water patiently rises to
the surface it's been called the the
shipwreck shark because they're sort of
infamous stories about them taking out
sailors that were shipwrecked that are
drifting at sea but there's an animal
that has to be very efficient at hunting
you know the open ocean has been
described as a desert and there's only
pockets of life here and here and there
so these animals have to be very very
good at what they do
oceanic tend to be generally in size
between nine and twelve feet in length
and they have those beautiful long Hecht
oral fins not unlike the thresher or the
blue shark that we saw but even longer
they're their scientific name their
latin name is Lunger manis which when
translated means the long hand or the
long fingers which is an apt description
you can imagine an animal like this you
know swimming up toward the surface and
then just gliding down maybe a mile deep
into the ocean looking for prey
completely effortlessly you know with
its pectoral those thermal denticles
completely hydrodynamic just swooping in
silently and and nailing some deepwater
fish very efficient predator and this
one as you can see is kind of kind of
beefy kind of fat so there's no no
problem getting food there's an image I
made that shows that that distinct shape
of the silhouette shape this was in a
place called Cat Island in the Bahamas
and it was back in 2006 that I did an
expedition there as part of a story I
was doing for National Geographic
because we had heard some fish tales
about oceanic whitetips being seen there
now she anacs hadn't been seen I didn't
know any diver that had seen one in 20
or 30 years in the Bahamas but the sport
fishermen said they were catching
yellowfin tuna and as they were reeling
in the tuna
they said that Oceanics were stealing
the fish off their their their lines so
on that that gamble I went out there for
16 days and 16 days only found
one but I brought a cage along because
we didn't know what we would find this
is West Pratt a shark biologist inside
turns out we were there at the wrong
time of year but if you go at different
times a year you can see more oceanic
whitetips but oceanic whitetips
as recently as about 1970 or in the
early 70s were described as the most
abundant large animal on the planet most
abundant large animal large meaning
anything bigger than a hundred pounds so
think about that there must have been
billions of them out there today
they're 99% in decline they're on the
verge of extinction
largely because of their fins their fins
are highly prized in shark fin soup Cat
Island in the Bahamas is one of the only
remaining pockets of oceanic whitetip
sharks left on the planet you can find
them in Hawaii a little bit sporadically
you can find them in the Red Sea but
this is really one of the only
concentrations it's my friend joe
romeiro a shark cameraman swimming with
one of them here so it's one of the only
places you could go to photograph them
and for this story it's where I spend my
time we have two of them here it's like
one is saying to the other one don't
look now but there's a guy taking our
picture over there but you know it's
it's all done with free dining we're not
using scuba with this so we're just
snorkeling math snorkeling fins and a
wetsuit and it can get a little
interesting when there's several of them
around there's three in this particular
frame especially when the ocean is a
little rough they'll come in and oceanic
whitetips will often bump you know I've
never seen their teeth but unlike them
you know some of the other species that
a little bit more standoffish
they are quite curious and they will
come in it bump and when they do that
nictitating membrane that white membrane
goes over their eye to protect them you
know so if they were attacking prey that
might scratch their eye it's an
evolutionary thing that they've
developed but beautiful animals and on
one of my last days there I photographed
this pair and the one in the foreground
as you see has a satellite tag on it
near the dorsal fin and these are
researchers that have begun to tag these
animals and try to track their movements
they don't stay at Cat Island we're not
quite sure I think where they're going
so we need to know that information if
we're going to be able to protect them
Bahamas has protected all sharks which
is a very good and progressive thing to
do but if they go somewhere else and get
killed that wouldn't be good so it's
going to be helpful to have that
that sort of information so I have
another little video of what it's like
dining at Cat Island with them here
whoops I maybe we don't alright well
we'll do go right to great white sharks
how's that so the last species of course
is his great white sharks that I wanted
to share with you tonight
and as you may know great whites are the
largest predatory fish on earth an
absolute ultimate predator this is an
animal that can weigh well over a ton
and has more than 300 big serrated teeth
in its mouth and it can grow to the
length of at least 20 feet some
anecdotal reports of big ones out there
but we know at least 20 feet but it's an
animal that is largely enigmatic we know
very little about great whites we we
don't know how many there are or very
much about them in the places that we
even get to see brief glimpses now you
can imagine a terrestrial predator the
size of a pickup truck hunting along the
coast of California you know we would
know everything there is to know about
that animal but in the sea that's not
the case you know we don't get that kind
of access so they do remain largely and
IgG Matic and and very mysterious for
this story in in the July issue National
Geographic I worked in two locations the
first of which was South Australia and I
I went to Australia because it was a
place where I thought I had a pretty
good chance of seeing sharks you know
the first job and doing these stories is
to be able to see the thing you want to
try to photograph and sometimes
underwater that's not always so easy but
it was also a location which great white
sharks have been observed and studied
for a very long time and there there are
some new theories emerging about them
you know there's various hubs I mean it
was always believed that great whites
were loners that they pretty much
warranted the ocean alone by themselves
but we know now that there is some
social behavior there are these hubs
where they tend to congregate often for
feeding or mating but not much is really
known about those social behaviors this
is a photo that I I made at dusk when we
see two great whites sort of moving in
in this hunting behavior they often get
very frisky at at sunset time but you
know besides things the complex
behaviors like social behaviors as I
said we we really don't know very much
about anything else with these animals
we we see some patterns and in their
migratory behavior some seem to follow
certain little highways in the ocean but
others are very random it's not really
understood and we've never seen them
mate we don't know where great whites
are having your pups within nursery
grounds are again there's some theories
is one often New York that was described
this year but a lot more has to be done
on that and as I mentioned earlier - we
don't even know how many there are in
the world we can't decide if they're
endangered or not most scientists would
think that they are but there are those
who think the population is increasing
while others think they're declining
until recently it was believed that
great whites only live to about 35 years
old but a new paper came out last year
that said that they live well into their
70s so imagine this this predator that's
wandering thousands of miles in the
course of a year and living well into
its 70s you know what kind of wisdom
might an animal like that possess I
don't know that we'll ever tap into that
but certainly fun to think about for me
photographically Australia was a place
where I I could get close and make
pictures of these animals and try to
show that grace and power nothing like a
great white it just exudes confidence
and to the degree that I could do as a
degree that I could show it through
photography their personality you know I
think all animals have personalities and
sharks certainly do Tigers have a
different personality than great whites
but even within a single species you
know some sharks are a little more bold
others are shy this was a an animal that
had a broken dorsal fin and her
personality was pretty mean she was not
very happy I think she didn't like
having that broken dorsal there but it
was also a South Australia was the only
place in the world that I knew of where
I could make bottom pictures here most
of the white shark photos we see are up
in the water column in the blue water
but this was a place where the operator
I was working with had a bottom cage and
we could send it down 60 to 80 feet or
so and have a chance of seeing
so to the benthic region now it was a
tricky thing to do because the cage was
always moving with the boat moved the
cage was bouncing along the bottom so
and there was also this big wall of
silver jacks these fish that would just
you know like a curtain of mirrors all
around so in order to make this photo
which I hadn't really seen anything like
this before I had to open the door of
the cage and sort of lean out and punch
through that wall of fish scattered the
fish and then for a few seconds I saw
this white shark you know swimming
through this forest coming towards this
this way they do predate on raised this
one didn't get eaten but they're also
there to eat seals but you know a
different view that might engage the
reader the magazine's want to know more
about these these amazing creatures I
also worked in in surface cages out
there as well
I didn't ever get out of the cage
because there's always a lot of sharks
that was usually at least three or four
of them around and and they were
checking you out I mean they would come
right in this was one on a sort of a
rainy rough day at the surface and the
operator I was working with had a
single-person cage but he doesn't
usually use but he let me use it
everything he doesn't let most people
use it is because it has these big
openings in it and sometimes the white
sharks can get a little curious and
they'll start poking their nose in now
usually when they get curious you just
poke them with your camera housing and
they get deterred and they swim away but
I had one day when about a 14-foot male
was a little over anxious and sort of
just started coming in and he ended up
getting caught between my strobe cord
and my strobe arm and he ended up
ripping the the strobe cord off the
camera how they almost lost the entire
rig it's about a thirty twenty five
thousand dollar rig I ended up just
losing a $3,000 strobe but Trevor Frost
who's in the audience tonight was
assisting me there and he had a GoPro in
the water so I'm going to show a little
clip that shows me try to wrestle this
shark to get my camera back at the end I
didn't have fins on so I was walking up
the side of the cage can't see it that
great but anyway we'll have a look
[Music]
oh well I'm pretty sure I got it
yeah so I lost the strobe but I kept the
camera so that was the good news well
the other location for this story the
last location for the evening here is
Cape Cod Massachusetts my home waters
where I live and where I started out and
what's happening in Cape Cod is is
actually unique I think in the animal
kingdom what we have is a newly emerging
hub for white shark activity there's
about five known hubs of white shark
activity in the world but Cape Cod is
the newest one
and it's only started happening since
about 2009 when the white sharks have
reemerged here and this would be
analogous to a new pride of lions
emerging in Serengeti I'm not aware of
any other new group of predators just
sort of taking up residency somewhere
but that's what's happening in Cape Cod
it seems as though there's some
anthropological evidence that seems to
indicate that there was a robust seal
population in Massachusetts back in the
1600s around the time that the pilgrims
came there but they were wiped out by
sealers so they were gone for hundreds
of years but in 1972 with the Marine
Mammal Protection Act they were
protected and these seals have slowly
come back and over time the Sharks have
come back as well Chatham is sort of the
epicenter of all this activity in the
middle of Cape Cod and they have sort of
embraced their shark enos all kinds of
little knickknacks and Sharky stuff for
sale and many of the gift shops at least
until something happens but but yeah so
this is where I worked I spent two
seasons out there trying to tell this
emerging story very difficult place to
work but this is why the Sharks are
there as I mentioned the the growing
number of gray seals this is what's the
dinner
at least if you're a great white shark
they seem to be singularly focused on
seals they're not feeding on fish or
anything else they just come here to
feed on the seals and this is an aerial
photo I made of one of these great
whites you can see in the lower right of
the frame and all those seals they're
hunting in very very shallow water you
know most of the literature that exists
all of the literature that exists so
is that for a great white shark to hunt
a pinniped a seal it needs about 80 feet
of water to ambush them but we've been
documenting predation in shallow is 5 or
10 feet of water so this is a unique
strategy unique in the world not all of
their attacks are successful this was a
grey seal that was attacked and and got
away but it did actually die later so
they're not always I don't know what
their success rate is it hasn't been
measured but but that's what's going on
there but in the years since 2009 the
state biologists with math state
fisheries a friend of mine Greg skomal
has been conducting a population study
what he does is he goes out on a boat
with a big pulpit like this we use
spotter planes to help find the sharks
and then we get our boat in position or
he gets his boat in position and he'll
put a little GoPro camera on the end of
a long pole and try to get some video of
it in each shark has unique markings
they might have scars or different
countershading patterns on them so he's
been able to identify in just the last
few years over 200 individuals so you
know jaws was about one shark we've got
over 200 at least and and no doubt
there's going to be a lot more but you
can also see in this picture I made of
Greg doing that study how close they
come to the beach this is nice at beach
in Orleans which is right near Chatham
most popular beach on on Cape Cod and I
was out there for two seasons and every
day you know I'd see surfers and boogie
borders and people one day they these
guys saw me out there in the boat and
they scratched in the words shark with a
question mark on the beach there so so I
climbed up on top of the pilothouse and
I yelled yes this this there is one
right here so far as we've been able to
coexist and the shark seemed very
discriminating about what they're
hunting but but who knows but
photographically this was one of the
most difficult things I've ever done
these are completely wild sharks they
can't be Chum din they have no interest
as a rule in coming close to the boat
the researchers up there have used all
kinds of you know attractants and things
and nothing works to get them close to
the boat so my first season up there the
best I could do was with a pole cam
this is a picture I made while our boat
was underway of one of these giant great
white sharks in that very murky water
there's lots of currents you couldn't
use a cage there you wouldn't see
anything and the currents would blow it
over
pretty impressive tail zone right sure
but I eventually figured that what I
needed to do was build a seal decoy so
so I went back to my friends at Woods
Hole and we built this big grey seal we
try to make it as authentic as possible
like an adult of gray CLI skull had the
head sculpted by a model maker and we
put cameras inside with fiber optic
cables and you know I could watch in
real time and live view back on the boat
we had a little wetsuit carved like a
seal body here and we would deploy it
day and night day and night day and
night and nothing sharks had absolutely
no interest they were laughing as they
gave me the finger as they swam by and
that was about it
so over the winter I went home dejected
and you know wasn't sure I was going to
have a story I didn't know if I'd get
any pictures but over the winter I
talked to a friend of mine who's a
veterinarian on Cape Cod and also a
shark researcher and he had also been
working on his own seal decoy design and
he had perfected it he got it to a point
where it was a much simpler design a
much smaller seal design only about
maybe 3 or 4 feet in length and he said
he was having a little bit of success
with this so I took his design and I
adapted my cameras to what I needed to
do was put a wireless underwater camera
in there that I could trigger from
hundreds of yards away I didn't want any
cables in the water and I also had to
have real-time video in there as well
that I could see on the boat so I
deployed these a last summer and the
Sharks were interested now the trick was
he wanted one that would come up and
check it out but she didn't want one
that would eat it because that would
that would be very bad you you and that
happened it happened on a number of
occasions where the great white would
come up and destroy the seal decoy we
had ones that didn't have cameras in
them but so this is you know this is
maybe 30 or 40 yards off Monomoy beach
in Chatham when this picture was
published in the July issue the Cape Cod
chamber commerce was especially pleased
they they sent me thank you
note but but it's an interesting
behavior now you know what's happening
here it's not like South Africa where
these animals are breaching out of the
water and so forth but it is unique in
the world and there's a lot more that
needs to be studied I have a little
video that shows some of that decoy work
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so using that system I was able to
produce the very first underwater
pictures of a great white shark in Cape
Cod waters one of these days where the
shark just sort of was curious came up
to the seal and using that rig on the
boat where I had video I could I could
remotely fire fire the camera wirelessly
fire it and make these portraits you can
see very shallow water shadow a shadow
on the bottom maybe five feet depth here
of water and very murky as one had pilot
fish with it and this one i named mike
tyson because he had a little tattoo on
his face there I think those are
scratches from a seal but you know I
think we certainly have a very long way
to go in truly understanding these
sharks we may never understand him but
each year I think we're peeling back
layers and learning a little bit more
and you know I have to say that despite
the devastating decline of sharks all
species of sharks around the planet I
think we're maybe at a point now where
we're turning the corner where we're
beginning to appreciate these animals
through photography and film we're
creating a new ethic and maybe we're
coming to the understanding that the
world is indeed a better place with
sharks in it so in closing I think back
to when I began looking like Liberace
here many decades ago when I was
spending time on stinky fishing boats
ladling chum into the sea in hopes of
just seeing a shark and I didn't know
then those decades ago that in the years
ahead I would actually find myself in
the company of many many sharks and I
couldn't have known then that I would
come to see these animals as a species
in peril that for all their strength
they remain fragile and completely
powerless against the overfishing that's
eradicating them from our oceans so all
these years later I find myself still on
boats and less than comfortable
conditions decades spent at sea which is
the price I pay for just a few precious
moments underwater in the company of
these magnificent animals where I try to
shine a light on them and help to tell
their story so to end I started with my
blue shark story my very first and I
want
with a little video that was done while
I was on Rhode Island it was a one-hour
documentary in the National Geographic
Channel about my shark work and this was
in Rhode Island when I was looking for
Makos but I found my old friends the
blue sharks so that'll be the wrap-up
my Mako story continues this is the
third location in which I've worked I
started in San Diego California and
earlier this year I was in New Zealand
but these are my home waters you know
New England is is where I first started
diving
[Music]
so over the last several days we've seen
some Makos but they've been a little bit
shy they haven't really come in close to
the camera but today was a spectacular
day with blue sharks you know blue
sharks were the very first species of
shark that I ever photographed I think
it was 1982 when I was out in these same
waters and spent an afternoon swimming
with a blue shark so I have a real fun
place in my heart for these animals
they're also stunningly beautiful you
know they're shaped like a an aircraft
with these big pectoral fins or like the
wings of a glider and this wrong blender
fuselage like body and their indigo
backs and of this coloration is really
quite exquisite to see one or two on
recent trips it was sort of the average
but today we really hit the jackpot we
had over a dozen I'd say maybe 15 or
more and it's a nice opportunity when
the Sun begins to go down to start
making some dramatic pictures I'd love
to work in low-light where I have some
control over the colors and your
movements of the animals a great
opportunity for photography even though
it wasn't the prime target and what I'm
trying to do with this is bring readers
into the world of the shark and you see
one when you actually see an animal like
a mako shark underwater you just can't
believe that nature has sculpted
something so perfect seeing a dozen or
more blue sharks here today was a
hopeful thing for me
I know that their numbers have been
decimated throughout the Atlantic Ocean
and this is somewhat of an anomaly but
it does give me hope
I believe we're at a moment where the
traction is occurring we're making some
momentum and this continues we all keep
beating that drum
I think the future could be bright thank
you very much
[Applause]